[Music]
Marvel's MCU has had incredible run
starting off in 2008 with the Seminole
Ironman the franchise has grown to
become the biggest cinematic universe in
movie history
the creative team have pushed the
boundaries in several ways and whilst
their work is often imitated it is
unrivaled after watching through the
entirety of the MCU three times yes
three times I've ranked the film's from
worst to best this was a labor of love
and took a lot of time so whether you
agree or disagree with my list please
let me know your favorites without the
way I'm definition and this is my
ranking of the MCU all the Wikus of the
MCU films Thor centers around the origin
of the god of thunder starring Chris
Hemsworth Natalie Portman and Anthony
Hopkins this film tells the tale of door
traveling to Earth after being cast out
of his realm as God suffering from an
underdeveloped love story and weak third
act
Thor fails to really deliver on the
quality that the MCU is being known for
The Incredible Hulk The Incredible Hulk
was a cause correction from the previous
Angry version starring Ed Norton and
distributed by Universal this movie
feels almost alien to the rest of the
MCU and whilst the film starts off
excellently it devolves into a rather
banal and predictable climax that makes
it easily skippable in the overall run
Ironman to the weakest of the Ironman
trilogy this film's suffered heavily due
to the writers strike I still really
enjoy it but there's clearly problems in
the film and this is definitely the
worst Black Widow performance this movie
struggles with a sophomore curse and
feels like a step down from the seminal
film that preceded it Thor the dark
world Thor the dark world has gotten
better with age but it's still
criminally under use its villain and
feels like a stopgap between Avengers
movies it betters the use of its
as opposed to its predecessor but it
certainly doesn't do enough good to rank
higher in this list which is a shame as
there's a lot of cool character moments
that really make the god of thunder
infinitely more endearing and man in the
wasp and man in the wasp is the weakest
film of base-3 in my opinion due to its
underused villains cumbersome plot and
lack of logic surrounding some returning
characters whilst there is amazing set
design and some fantastic moments in my
opinion the film fails to capture the
level of humor from the first movie and
doesn't really feel like it a trances
beyond a film in any way I would have
loved to have ranked this higher but
unfortunately for me it falls flat
Captain America the First Avenger the
only period piece from the MCU Captain
America the First Avenger perfectly
introduces one of comics longest-running
characters featuring a brilliant bellman
Red Skull his film depicts the cab
taking on Nazis in World War two it
brilliantly deconstructs how cap was
used as propaganda in the war whilst
nailing down the fundamentals of what it
takes to be a hero this lays the
groundwork for what is to come and does
a brilliant job with the source material
Iron Man 3 Iron Man 3 deals with a lot
of heavy subject matters such as
post-traumatic stress disorder and
politics were it not for the net jerking
twist that comes at the film's midpoint
this movie would rank a lot higher
it features astounding action scenes and
balances the drama beautifully with
comedy it's just a shame that there were
some inexcusable choices that means this
ranks far down the list Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange introduces magic to the
MCU and does so in stunning fashion the
incredible visuals and performance by
Benedict Cumberbatch really captured my
imagination on first viewing and as film
has stayed with me over time
relying heavily on the Marvel formula
and being quite derivative of Batman
Begins early on keeps his phone below
the rest of the list but there's still a
lot to like here guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 guardians 2 misses out on meaning
more due to its clear derivative aspects
of The Empire Strikes Back this is a fun
film but it fails to capitalize fully on
its predecessor emotionally feeling
shallow at points I struggle slightly
with the movie but there's a lot of fun
aspects that evolved the characters in
more ways than one and anything with
baby groove in it deserves someone
ant-man ant-man heavily follows the
Marvel formula but pulls it off in a
much better way than Doctor Strange does
in my opinion laced with jokes this
comedy has laugh-out-loud funny and has
the visual flair to match never before
had we seen a character that was able to
shrink down to atom size and a unique
perspective that the hero provides makes
us in an endearing film in what cinemas
biggest franchise Avengers age of Ultron
age of Ultron is a guilty pleasure of
mine it develops the central casts in
more ways than one and features amazing
battle scenes such as the opener and the
Hulkbuster fight the film really pits
Tony against the rest of the team and
starts the divide that would come to
fruition in Civil War
disliked at the time due to the amount
of plot threads that leaves dangling
this film works better in retrospect and
definitely deserves a revisit now that
we have all of the information on the
table guardians of the galaxy
guardians was a huge risk for Marvel
this cast of characters were practically
unknown to all but the most die-hard
Marvel fans but due to amazing casting
and razor-sharp writing the guardians
were able to stand center stage in the
MCU and compete with the a-listers that
surrounded them the film made several of
its stars household names and is
hilarious from start to finish
it also teases a lot of what is to come
and this is good today as it was
upon release Captain America the Winter
Soldier Captain America the Winter
Soldier is a conspiracy theorists dream
possessing huge reveals from start to
finish this film really cemented cap as
one of the most remarkable characters in
the MCU
and is a blast from start to finish
centering around the captain's
relationship with former ally Bucky
Barnes the movie has a heart to it that
is near unrivaled it would go on to play
a big part of the Marvel Universe and
definitely feels more adult in tone than
the other films in the genre making it
better every time you watch it black
panther black panther now stands as one
of the highest-grossing movies ever made
it's no surprise as the story has a
superhero like no other and a complex
villain that provides a lot of
thought-provoking discussion on aspects
such as race and revolution I was blown
away by the film upon first viewing and
the movie stands as a milestone not only
first phenomenal profit but also for the
fact that it is the first film to really
bring a representation of Africa to
Hollywood in such a positive light
spider-man homecoming spider-man
homecoming is by far the best webhead
movie ever made this highschool centric
film perfectly captures Peter Parker
having to deal with his dual identities
whilst trying to live a normal life
Michael Keaton delivers a standout
performance as the heroes antagonist and
there are several action set pieces that
beautifully showcased by these full
range of abilities this one isn't to be
missed and its outstanding coming-of-age
story is relatable on many levels that
cemented as one of the best door
ragnarok thor ragnarok completely
reinvents the thunder god character and
is all the better for it
played for laughs this Beach eristic 80s
retro action adventure takes all of the
right boxes and manages to incorporate
several legendary graphic novels such as
Planet Hulk beautifully into its arc
Jeff Goldblum will have your
side-splitting
cog will have you on the
and by the end of the film you will view
the characters in a way like never
before
this film works great on several levels
and is a blast from start to finish
Ironman the first film in the MCU really
knocked it out of the park in my opinion
Ironman is a masterpiece in terms of
casting pace and effects it nails the
Marvel formula right off the bat and is
a character defining journey from start
to finish what I love about Ironman is
that it captures your imagination from
the get-go
and leaves you wanting more the movie
beautifully teases the Avengers but to
works perfectly as a standalone piece I
can't really fault the film and this is
one of the best Avengers Assemble
The Avengers film was a trendsetter
responsible for all of the shared
universe films that would try and copy
it success this still stands as the best
the dialogue provided by Joss Whedon is
perfect and it cannot be credited enough
for the influence that would have on
films and comic book genre following its
release this was a worldwide phenomenon
and was a landmark moment in movie
history that is arguably one of its most
important the film was a balancing act
but it manages to pull it off perfectly
and catapults this film to the forefront
of the list Captain America Civil War
Captain America Civil War is incredible
from start to finish
pitting the Marvel cast of characters
against one another it perfectly bounces
action with drama and has many
thought-provoking aspects that discuss
how all actions have consequences both
sides of the argument have their pros
and cons and it's easy to get caught up
in debates of privacy and foreign policy
when watching this film and its hardness
this story of friendship and it's one
that I constantly come back to you
because of its incredible character
development it introduces spider-man
black panther and much more and only
just misses out on the top spot due to
the next entry
Avengers infinity war ten years in the
making Avengers infinity war as an
ambitious crossover that Manchester
succeed in its goals of uniting the
Marvel Universe to tackle a threat of
Thanos beautifully paced acted and
presented the film is an instant classic
due to the film's relatability and the
epic battle scenes that span it's two
and a half hour runtime I was blown away
by how poetic and emotionally charged
the film was and somehow it manages to
balance all of this gravitas with a
humorous side that will appeal to even
the most stalwart is infinity war is an
incredible trial that I still cannot
believe they managed to pull off due to
the amount of characters and
interlocking plot lines the film manages
not only to meet expectations but
exceeds them in every way and that's why
it ranks is my favorite MCU film as with
all of my lists I'd love to hear your
thoughts do you agree
what's your top 5 comment below and let
me know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly they'll definitely be something
on here that you love if you're a fan of
film make sure you check out my
breakdown on how to survive this
Stormbreaker attack at the end of
infinity war which is linked at the end
of this video and again thanks for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]